[Music]
what's the biggest story lately
President Barack Obama's recent
endorsement of gay marriage and that has
been actually there's been in a bit of a
side effect to it which is a boon to
businesses everywhere that's right
including this relatively new sponsor of
ours hello gays and congratulations on
the president's recent endorsement of
same-sex marriage
you must be so excited to get gay
married ASAP but if you do remember to
make dumb decisions too and that's where
we come in where's Mickey it's Mickey
gave divorce attorneys we are not gay
attorneys who specialize in regular
divorce we are straight attorneys for
specializing gay divorce listen to my
brother typical story you've fallen gay
love so you get gay married everything's
going gay fine then you hit a gay bump
in the road like this 100% real gay
couple argue argue oh
let's get gay divorce now no what you
think you're not into straight men who
owned a small business located in a
strip mall in Paramus New Jersey
possibly facilitate the legal
dissolution of my gay marriage don't
worry about it we'll wish you gave
divorced in no gates at all now Schmidt
beans man if he just off route 9 in the
premise ball between the Orange Julius
in the Cinnabon if you see the Border's
books you walk too far
[Applause]